Hello everybody! My name Markiplier and today I'm
gonna be showing you
my greatest shame. *smiles*
Ever since i played Insanity Clicker
you guys have mentioned that it was a clone
of Clicker Heroes, which is a game
I never played before!
(high-pitched) So i thought what the hell! I'll give it a go,
it could be fun. [laughing] You guys wouldn't lie to me!
and so I- I got it for my phone,
*inhale*
*pauses*
and it has consumed my life.
Everything about my life is gone now and it's been replaced by this stupid rat
in front of me and I gotta click him.
I gotta kill him until he's dead!
And I'm at such a high level now
I've been playing sooo loooong,
and I mean it- I know it hasn't been that long
since I played Insanity Clicker
I'VE BEEN PLAYING NON-STOP ON THIS
like, every waking moment it's been open on my phone.
I had to get a battery case, FOR MY PHONE
FOR IT TO LAST LONGER SO I CAN PLAY IT MORE
It's bullshit, (high-pitched) this game is bullshit!
I'm not sponsored by this game in any way, it's fuckin' bullshit
Don't get it!
It'll consume your life!!
I'VE SPENT R E A L MONEY ON THIS!
(very high-pitched) I- I hate it!
But I love it! *boink*
But I hate it!
But I love it.
Oh and I didn't even need to spend real money on it
it gave me enough free stuff anyway that I was able to get it
that's all the gems that I've earned,
but it's so bullshit! Goddammit
I thought Insanity Clicker was cool
just because of the cool monsters that it showed by.
This- this fucking, imp-
oh it's a- it's a possum it's not even a rat
what ever fuck you just, ehhhhh
But anyway, what I wanted to show you
is, I'm at a high level.
I'm at an absurdly high level
where the numbers don't even have any meaning anymore
and it may seem like i have 1388% gold
that percent means
What does it mean?
1 octodecillion,
which is, a lot.
It's like,
ten to the *mark.exe working* power of 18... I have no idea
it's a big number
I- Why!!! It's a number
god- a fucking noombers!
But I keep chasing them, (angrily) I can't STOP!
But anyway, so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna show you why I'm so freaking consumed with it
and I'm gonna
Imma engage some uhh
storming power here and I
I- ergh
I don't know what the most efficient thing is but I just doubled my tap storm
for those of you- know click- I don't
I don't frickin know whatever and
then i tap with the fury of a thousand hells
I gotta... put on progression or else I'm not gonna be able to beat this boss...
but yeah!!!! gimme more heroes souls primal mama ferny mamma bat
what ever the fuck you are
*cries*
its consumed my life
i've lost everything to this game
all my friends, Chica doesn't love me anymore
i don't take her outside she just POOPS with reckless abandon on my bed
*cries loudly*
*inhales* Anyway once this is done I'm gonna
restart the game because that's the
basic concept of the game you play it
until you restart it and then hopefully
you get a little farther than you did
before and like I have these these
artifacts that help you progress through
the game which like reduce the number of
enemies you need to kill, reduce boss
health, stuff like that
and that's all well and good and I even-- I've
got a bunch of ~~Gilded Heroes~~ which just
means that they're slightly better than they
were before and you know i got all my
guys who are level way too freaking high
and shit money's too fucking expensive and
the reason i can't progress any more
from where i am now is because my combo
is too low but if you notice at the top
it says the blue thing they're the
little swirly windy symbol
those are heroes souls so as you
progress in the higher levels you kill
certain bosses that give you hero soul's *sarcasm ensues* but only when you restart your game
over again isn't that a handy dandy tool so
the guy that does that is this guy a
Amenhotep some Egyptian
pharaoh at some point or god I'm not a
hundred percent sure on that one don't
quote me but when I start this *boink* it
*bombastically* will reset the game and you'll start a
new game with 852 more hero souls will
also keep your rubies and ancients you
will gain 8520 percent damage to all
damage from hero souls so that sounds
nice right?
*high pitched* hey start at the beginning but I WAS AT LEVEL FIVE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SHIT
it was a lot i just threw it all away
for a few more heroes souls
if you're wondering what hero souls are
spent on, these fuckers with their shit
in their ball ass in their stupidity and
their usefulness and cool features that
allow you to kill a guy like this *boink*
and he's dead
how about that . . (high-pitched) boink boink boink
boink boink boink boink boink . and
they're dead
and then i can get these guys who're
gonna kill him for me way
faster than they should die like
unbelievably quickly they just fall over
and die and then I gather more gold
more more more more more more more more
until you figure that maybe maybe it's
time to put down the game
maybe it's time to not let it consume
you; maybe it's time to actually go
outside and play with Chica, my dog,
and you know see another human for the
first time and stop getting Chipotle
delivered to my house because that's a
fun feature that I learned and has
caused me to never go outside
*high pitched screaming* FUCK YOU! I GOT CLICKING TO DO!
anyway. so this is-- if you-- if you're wondering if
it gets like, anymore, or what the hell
I'm doing
I've done this so many times that and m-my damage has been multiplied so many
times that as I'm starting out I get to
like level a hundred and fifty before i
can even see or even am-- am capable of
clicking on anything before it just dies
and then you get more gold and you hire
more badasses that can do more damage
and then everything is hunky-dory *smiles in pain, inhales*
it's crazy.. this craziness is consuming
you can also level up by hundreds
because who has time to click am i right?
*awkward*
no one...no one has time to click.
so as you can see i'm already at the
billions of gold level i'm getting
literally billions of gold and I'm
smashing through bosses like they're
nothing. If you came here to see these
cool creatures, too bad! They're gone.
so as I-- I can-- There's also a convenient
feature to buy all upgrades *boink* and
then... this happens! They die!!! More and
faster and better than before and
everything is created in my life *cries*
stop questioning the habit as I have! *more crying*
(mark sounds) I swear like my computer's-m-my phone spend so much processing power
trying to calculate the gigantic numbers
that it actually causes the batteries
ooze out the sides of my thing
not faaaaast enough...oh man that boss almost lasted a few seconds what is this
bullshit???????
I will not haaaaaave this in my house-- ah get out of here
I will not haaave this in my house.*cries quietly* I will not have this in my house ah get out my face goddamn it
Godammit I'm getting, I'm getting...
oh fuck off try to be quick about this
and I'm doing everything wrong *boink* more
damage
more more MORE also the combo system if
you're wondering about that in the top right
basically as I'm playing each time I
click it adds to the active combo
so I can't close the app or else it
won't keep combo
it will go away and for every hit I get
like . one percent more damage but you
can click like thousands of times in a
session if I'm actually serious about
clicking which I'll show you my patented
double thumb technique literally just
tapping with my thumbs
I-- i di- i do the finger you know the
double tap with that tires my hand out i
could actually keep up the up never mind
it's not important information oh by the
hundreds i don't have time
tiiiime to waaaaste on yoooouuuu *singing* dooooon't have time to waaaaaaste on yoooooou. I don't have time to waste on you!
on you
*continues singing in perfection* I wiiiiish I haaaaad my liiiife baaaaack i wish
i had
my old friends *cries yet again*
who needs friends when you have the reward
of ever exponentially increasing numbers
because that's all life's about
I for all the shit I for all the shit I
give this game
there actually is a reason that it's
addicting and it's it's a satisfaction
thing at least that's what i theorize
it's just very satisfying made like
it's satisfying to hit them because they do a
little animation
it's very colorful the gold sprays
everywhere
it's just like it's designed that way
and i guess i can commend the developers
for doing that but I'm not gonna
so now i'm going to recommend this game
even though the end of this video I'm
going to ask you to join my clan so that
i can get more heroes souls
ok so i've reached kind of the end of
the end of the heroes all have for a
while the next level is dread Knight and
I won't be able to get dreadknight for a
long time because dreadknight costs the
jump between like frost leaves cost 403
non million million million
ya know deicilian and the dread Knight
cost three more powers of ten more than
frost leaf and the difference between
those numbers may not seem like a lot
but it's a frickin huge amount it will
be a hundred levels before i can even
get one dreadknight so for now I just
gotta kinda gotta go with the flow on
the beginning here and oddly enough when
you get to this level and everything is
getting all hunky-dory that's am attempt
for resetting but I don't want to reset
yet because I
i want more hero levels before i reset and then i'll
be able to be more damage next time and
and relive this wonderful moment all over
again *crazy laugh* but the only way to compete is
these guys level up yes you spend money
on level up but that's a linear process
because and if you don't know the
difference between linear and
exponential process then you won't be
able to wrap your hands around this
but the the point of this is
I'm upgrading by levels of 25 because
every 25 levels past the last upgrade
thing you have and they each have
individual upgrade systems here that you
can see but every 25 levels past the
last upgrade you have or think maybe it
starts at two hundred they will start
quadrupling their damage every 25 levels
they upgrade so it ends up that your
first few creatures that you have become
like your most damaging creatures after
like once it it gets a while before the
next creature and gets involved but
these three guys right here Brittany
Ivan in the tree beasts they become the
heaviest hitters that I have they're
doing they're doing octillion or
decillian they're doing decillian levels
of damn they're doing n damage and
compare that to my frost leaf who still
only doing O damage and if you don't
know
o is before n in this scenario i
believe that's octillion which is two
powers of 10 below n so if that's
confusing
congratulations you're there with
everybody
so if you're a nerd like me who
likes numbers
this game is going to appeal to you huh so
up in the top left you get more hero
souls obviously the higher you climb i
was up over 500 before but when you get
to every five levels you fight a boss
and the boss has a chance of being a
primal boss and what that means is the
primal bosses are the ones that offer
hero souls every primal boss or every
hundred levels you go up which takes a
long time but
the primal bosses which are little rare
give you hero souls on your next like
ascension that it calls and that's how
you eventually climb higher just by
keeping those heroes souls but if you
want to spend money you can actually use
them to upgrade and get more ancients
and when you have the ancients they have
things like 60 more seconds to boss
timer
more treasure chest more chance of
primal bosses more damage to critical
clicks which is very good
this is actually a level 200 boss he's
not a primal but he still gives zero
souls and that's how are you going
hey you can spend your roomies which you
do get a lot of when you're doing things
just because it's a very handy dandy to
be able to do it but you get a lot of
get a lot of rubies from achievements
and stuff and you can see the
achievements right there blah blah blah
okay but that's not important because i
don't care about that what is important
is this *more mark sounds* then you spam as hard as you can
yep this is fun the idea of fun
so anyway that is clicker heroes if I
had the time I would be here for hours
because that's what I do in my normal
day play this for hours *laughs in sadness* i know
i'm giving you mixed signals but I mean
I do enjoy the game but just be careful
little consumers will*yells*don't spend any
money don't be stupid like me don't do
it
it gives you so many free rubies you
don't need it but still join my clan to
join my clan
I have a clan by the name of the markipeeps if you want to join
I've got no members! NONE
and I'm trying to beat these raid bosses
and i'm gonna kick this guy's ass!
so if you join you'll see that this guy
is still up and you can fight him with
me and then we can fight him together
so watch as I kick his ass and try to
beat him and you know in a raid with
your clan everyone takes turns trying to
beat the crap out of this guy and get
more hero souls and then everybody can
collect once a day and do all that sort
of stuff right cool
ok so join up please find me I'm there
I'll add you well I'll add anyone andddddd *boink* ok
times up I did a lot of damage on him
but not as much as I wanted to do i did
a total of 756,000 so thats all i have to say
about this game
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you enjoyed this
well you must be as obsessed about the
game as I am but if you didn't enjoy
this I'm so sorry that my crippling
addiction has gotten you down in your day
good day
it gets me down too so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye-bye! *smiles and waves*
(Outro music plays)